and that's the real question if you
actually ask yourself what has
philanthropy
actually solved and it's not a lot like
think about them we put hundreds of
millions of dollars into
cancer research and solving hunger and
disaster relief or climate change and we
don't have real solutions
private philanthropy works in a couple
areas uh vaccines
coronavirus actually a good example but
malaria smallpox like crazy innovative
research where private philanthropists
can
take crazy risk prove concept and then
let the governments
or big in non-profit organizations who
are allowed to take risk
see that see it as a safer bet and then
pour resources into it
um but hunger homelessness cancer like
those are not places where private
philanthropy has really done well
so and at the risk of
making this redundant why can't private
philanthropy
solve hunger like one of the posts i saw
was saying how you know i'm gonna tell
my kids this is why one in three
children are hungry right now
because you have bezos instead of paying
income taxes is
you know flying his penis rocket to
space like why is that wrong
there's one that's treating the symptom
and they're treating the cure like the
cause of hunger right
so you can feed people and we do that
right um there's a lot of philanthropy
that's spent
like giving food to the hungry and that
is important that's like a
i call that like disaster relief there
are people in need we have to help them
and that's what philanthropy should be
doing it's also what our government
should be doing
in order to actually solve hunger we
probably should get an answer on this
but the biggest
challenge is not at least from what i've
researched it's not
a food quantity issue it's a
distribution issue it's a government
issue
it's a um i mean every government's
different um
so could but could a private individual
with enough money solve that
distribution
issue i mean if they were able to bribe
every single government official to get
them to do what they want
like i don't like you know and maybe
jeff bezos could create uh
on why don't you tell the world bank
story
when i was on wall street i i asked a
very senior
woman from the world bank and she well
she asked all of us if you had a
infinity money what would you use it to
what causes would you
um focus on to cure and solve and
everybody went around they said the
usual education this that anything
and then i flipped it back on her i was
like what would you do and she said i
would
use the money to bribe the men and
mainly men but the people in power
around the world
um to solve the most pressing problems
in the world um
because uh and that's probably
the only way you'd solve hunger because
you like jeff bezos is not
the government of india um where he can
like
india has a caste system right that they
believe that they're very poor have like
done something to deserve that um
fighting against there are problems that
are so big and this is a bill gates
thing that i've heard him say so this
makes some sense to me as i'm
learning about this like there are some
problems that are so huge
you actually need something at the scale
of government to solve them correct
and and yet gates talks about that like
there are things that you just can't
solve
privately so there's risks that
governments and businesses
um and that that's the challenge you
need the government to solve them and
sometimes the private sector but there
are certain risks that those areas
can't take like some ideas are too crazy
um
for a government if you're an elected
official you can't be betting on crazy
new technologies that are very expensive
because
people will find out if they don't work
you lose right you don't win your next
election
um the a lot
some of these really good ideas like
let's call it solving hunger and like a
local level
takes what they call patient capital
where it's like i have to build the
infrastructure
and the the community
and the the businesses need to grow and
the hospital needs to get better it's
like this slower and you don't make your
money back the way you would in a
business or you don't have the results
the way you'd want like a government
so that's where private philanthropy
should come in where they come in like
i'll put up the crazy risk i can i can
fail as a private philanthropist
because you can't but if it works then i
want you to scale it
um jaclyn novogratz we've had mike it's
the sister i believe it mike novogratz
who's been on this podcast um i started
an organization called acumen and her
whole thing
is about patient capital like building a
hospital that's not gonna have a roi in
the first five
10 20 years but over time that
government can pick up the tab because
it's starting
because the community is building and
the profit models start to work and as a
business or government can start to come
in
um so
a long way of saying um be like basil
should be solving world hunger and
helping us
he is donating i believe like giving 10
billion he's the number one
philanthropist in the world and so is
his
ex-wife i don't see a future where he's
not like pressured to give even more in
that world
um but also what are you gonna what is
he gonna do
like he's literally looking like how do
i give away
50 billion if i wanted to give away 100
billion dollars how the hell do i do
that and what am i solving you better do
something awesome like that's a really
hard challenge i'm not be like boo hoo
jeff bezos
but seriously it is very difficult and
if you listen to bill and melinda gates
talk about their foundation
they talk about how [ __ ] impossible
it is to give
money away an effective way that you
would the way you would invest it
um because these social problems are
complicated they are not black and white
they are not measured effectively
it's tough to measure and find results
guys so there's a concept
in philanthropy i think it's
philanthropy or in the world right
that's like
measure anything you're going to do with
your money against just giving it to
people
obviously that's a big thing you and i
are advocates for why shouldn't he just
you know figure out a way to do a
massive ubi or hell just like use his
personal wealth to pay amazon employees
more and just
use that money to just give it to other
people
that's not a bad one um we're talking
about two and a half percent of it so
here's the other thing
um and i wrote this down so i um
i don't think he's mutually this isn't
what we're talking about mutually
exclusive like him giving away
two and a half percent of his wealth for
the space race does not mean he can't
give hundreds of billions of dollars to
do
a ubi or something crazy um my concern
and if i was his advisor like find
something that's sustainable and not
you know curing the symptom for a short
period of time but that's a different
challenge
so the the big one for me and like why
space is actually
in my opinion relatively philanthropic
and has hot philanthropic and has
high roi there's a couple things one our
government's not doing it so if we
are passionate as a human race about
space exploration
billionaires have to step up that's
number one um
and philanthropies aren't doing it and
governments are seeing it's too risky
like it's too expensive and too risky
whatever it is
the second thing is it is massive upside
here both for-profit
and philanthropically and i think that
either
we popularized space travel
over time to the point where you could
take a rocket from here to london
and get there and you know from new york
to london and get there in
two hours or so and that would change a
whole bunch of ways we do business or
you start to colonize space yeah but
isn't there a good argument to be made
that says like oh yay now like you know
the already rich people essentially who
do global business can get to london a
little bit faster
but isn't it better if we again give
poor people money
instead of being able to do that that
like that advancement is not actually
great it's not it's not it's a fair
point but it's like
i don't know like how valuable is it
that we can have planes going like
people can travel across the country so
i will say okay so
and that's not just a rich people thing
but poor people children like the
average american is flying on a plane
once a year i imagine
um no no no i don't think so absolutely
not
poor americans certainly are not once a
year poor americans
we should look look that up but it is
not just business people traveling there
are plenty of people
you were saying you were going to london
do you know how
average americans are not going on
vacation london's a bad example but you
could take a rocket anywhere when people
will go and make it
cheaper for people to go to australia or
go see a relative who's across the world
one of the coolest comparisons i heard
was to
maritime travel in the 1400s which is
you know in 1450 if you were going to
take a ship
from spain for example to
some other part of the world which at
that point we didn't even know really
what existed because we hadn't fully
traversed the globe
it was incredibly risky it would have
seemed like a terrible use of money
because
the odds that you sunk or just
disappeared and never came back
etc were very very high
and yet what that exploration got us
was like insurance for the first time
like you know all sorts of things that
in modern day we actually value that are
good for any number of people and of
course like
we now live in a global world in ways
that are largely very beneficial
i mean there's obviously you can come at
me for like colonialism etc
um and so one of the things that we know
is being worked on as part of the space
race is global broadband
and being able to provide internet now
from satellites
to the entire world including people in
like third world countries who right now
don't have any access or you know very
little access to the internet and what
that has the potential to do
in terms of making a truly global
marketplace in terms of people suddenly
earning money
you know online in countries where you
know
whatever five dollars a day is is
incredible like there's a lot
that can be done here in terms of
bringing internet to the world and you
have things like space link i forget
who's doing that one of these
you know billionaires or it might be is
is working on space
which does satellites to bring broadband
et cetera so
i think um that did shift my perspective
a little bit of
what's being underestimated on the part
of people who are really opposed to this
is how much innovation can come out of
really important valuable innovation can
come out of
investing in in space and what the point
you're making which i think is
interesting
is that it should be private
philanthropists doing this
because the government should not be
taking on this kind of risk blowing this
kind of money
but that we should be doing it and so
the people who should be doing it
are exactly this and if the government
and if if elon
and rit branson and jeff bezos create
recyclable rockets that cut the cost
down go into space by 25 or 50 or 75
percent
and next you know we can travel to
saturn we're certain men on mars
eventually if we have to back up the
hard drive because of an extinction
level event on earth and we have to
colonize mars or the moon or
god forbid any stuff we'll be thanking
them and for
two and a half percent of his net worth
or whatever the heck like for this for a
drop in the bucket for jeff
this has high upside that no one else is
really willing or able to take so that
is my defense of this
the big one to me for those of you that
are like well billionaires shouldn't
exist this way that's the thing to me
don't hate the player hate the game like
what jeff bezos is doing theoretically
has massive upside for humanity
i don't think we should mad at him um
objectively i'm not a human being you
can be mad at me okay
here's a question for you though so anon
gyra dadas how do i pronounce his last
name
gyrados who wrote um winner take all or
whatever which was a book that yang
loves i know you love about
about basically how you get these people
sorry
yeah you get super rich and then they
give their money away a little bit and
pat themselves on the back and feel like
they've made a difference when really
they haven't so he wrote a book that
makes that argument
he has said about this and i'll shout
out griffshark i think was his name
somebody
username on our youtube comments last
time brought this to my attention which
i appreciate
um which was anon's argument that
basically
like america and what's great about
america was built on this balance
between what we do as a collective what
we do together
and then what we do alone and that this
whole billionaire space race
is an example of this balance being
totally out of whack
i'm curious on your thoughts on that one
thing that comes to mind for me is in
this maritime analogy i was making
uh a lot of those spa you know those
ship
explorations that happened in the 1400s
were a combination of private investors
and government investment
um which you know helps ensure that
there's a sort of collective benefit to
be had from it
i don't know what's your any thoughts on
that take so
i guess from my experience in talking to
the big philanthropists the issue is not
what's getting done
in some ways i think there's times where
government will have to make an
investment no one wants to make and you
like that but
other times philanthropists can do it
too so it's less about that the big one
to me
the biggest challenge of where
philanthropy is going is oversight and
bazel is not the best example because
that is um or at least like musk like
spacex a public company
um like blue i don't think blue origin
is public but it's like
there'll be some level of of oversight
there i guess
and plus it's very public but um like
they're making a big deal about it
but so there are a lot of
philanthropists
who wanted more flexibility than
starting a private foundation or
starting a non-profit so private
foundation you have to give away you
basically give all the money at one
point you get your tax deduction there
and then you have to give away
i believe it's like five percent a year
or so there's like required distribution
maybe ten percent depends on
but um uh it's been a while since i've
been doing it but at least five percent
um you have to give away a certain
amount a year but you don't the rest can
just be invested
um but that has rules and regulations
and uh the irs and
um are actually closely monitoring
private foundations those get audited a
lot um
what mark zuckerberg for example did
with his wife
they started they didn't even do it for
the tax purposes they started an llc
the chan zuckerberg initiative i think
it's called um their philanthropic
efforts are all done in a for-profit
vehicle just do what they want
which in one hand is really cool because
they can take crazy risk and do what
they want they don't have to get five
percent of you they don't have to worry
about
uh doing things that are purely
altruistic whatever it is but
there's no public accountability because
a non-profit is technically owned by the
public so there's no
awareness of who's on the board um
there's no
direct oversight what every dollar spent
on so things like that so that
um to me is the biggest challenge we're
supposed to do this stuff together
um or some of these things affect all of
us but there's no government oversight
on how it happens that's the biggest
challenge
okay well i think this is interesting i
want to wrap us to our our final topic
here bring us to our final topic here
donate the player hate the game carly
appreciate
your take on this you know maybe people
hate me that's like just
that's just so we need another no i
actually think you might bring defending
billionaires
no no you bring a certain amount of
knowledge to this that i think most
people don't actually have they don't
understand how it works and that's again
that's been a criticism i've heard of of
the people who are
criticizing the billionaires is that a
lot of these folks are like commentators
and haven't actually tried to like
solve these problems in a big way and
don't realize how hard it actually is
and that this
this this space work is actually really
valuable and then
critics man it's critics but there's
valid point i mean like richard branson
tried to get a bunch of money from
the uk government to bail out virgin
atlantic in ways that like
or virgin galactic or whatever that or i
think it's virgin atlantic whatever it's
just like it
that riles me up because i'm like let
capitalism do its thing let these
companies fail also you have 5.2 billion
dollars feel free to bail it out
yourself
if you're like you know so upset like
now you want government money like that
that does really get me oh the fact that
they don't pay income taxes i got plenty
of bonuses
yeah and that's now this is that's the
system not necessarily the billionaire
specifically but
it's um it's messed up
[Music]
okay speaking of money predict the
future
last topic well no i was going to say
that our final topic i think was going
to be stoner cats which is just
something we wanted to bring to people's
attention
okay so uh stoner cats
like gift goats which i talked about a
while back these nfts always have silly
names
that somehow involve animals um stoner
cast is an nft project being launched
really by mila kunis i guess but also
with ashton kutcher
fascinatingly vitalik buterin is
involved in this vitalik is the the
founder of
ethereum so that was cool that they got
him and uh
it is an nft project that was supposed
to drop chris rock
well okay we'll get there so this is
okay they're not actually really behind
the product though they're just actors
they're still involved
okay so let me give it to you so zach
this nft project was supposed to drop
yesterday as we're recording this it's
it's tuesday july 27th
when we record this um it was supposed
to drop yesterday monday at 2 00 p.m
pacific time
they had to push the launch back to
today um i'm gonna give a quick pro
launch already by the way by the time
this airs unless they push it back
unless they push it back okay i'm going
to give you the quick pros and cons and
the rundown the pros of this project is
it's really cool and innovative
basically if you buy one of these nfts
and they're going for like
0.35 eth which is like 800 bucks or
whatever
current prices it eats um if you buy one
of these
you it unlocks 45 minutes
of content created by some like
bigwigs in hollywood so you have like
the people who animated spider-man
who have you know a bunch of different
like animators people who created some
cool tv shows
and then this content is voiced by the
actors
are mila kunis ashton kutcher seth
macfarlane
jane fonda um who's the one i miss you
chris rock
and then vitalik buterin vitalik buterin
who's the founder of ethereum
and so it's like an all-star cast it
seems to be an all-star team creating
this animated series called stoner cats
and then there are all sorts of other
perks
like about cats like what could go wrong
is cats getting high
and there's all sorts of other benefits
if you become a token holder of this nft
like you get you know additional perks
and say in the content
and and the idea here is that this will
hopefully fund
other projects so it's the first example
that at least that i know of
of nfts basically funding like a
production company and putting the power
in the hands of the viewers as opposed
to in the hands of a traditional studio
those are the pros i think conceptually
super cool i'm investing in it because i
i love that concept i want to see more
of this
and hey like call out to the socialism
thing this is what you're talking about
like this is
the worker collective it's like the
money's all social things then i
oh my goodness calm down okay so and
then
the cons what are the cons
this team has not done a fantastic job
of building their community around this
project and
right now in nft world it is very
important to build a strong community
for your nft before it launches um and i
think
there's been two failings on this on
this front you have all of these
celebrity mainstream players
who are involved in this project and
they are doing very little to promote it
or to educate their audiences on how to
set up a metamask wallet for example and
therefore to buy an nft
using eth like they have not done the
requisite education piece
to draw in the mainstream audience and
they're also not letting you buy this
with a credit card it's like nba top
shot
is a is a nft project that's done very
well with the mainstream
because you can use a credit card for it
um so they have not
they don't have the infrastructure for
the mainstream and then and then they
have not
you know educated the mainstream on how
to buy eth which is a missed opportunity
on a whole bunch of friends seth
macfarlane isn't even tweeting about
this nor is chris rock et cetera
so that means the people they're
attracting are the
like crypto nft insiders who don't
really give an f that these people are
celebrities and just want like a cool
a cool project um and on this front
they've sort of delivered because the
project seems cool but they haven't
really like paid their respects to the
inner community to make them feel
comfortable and like they really know
what they're doing
so they had to delay the launch
yesterday because they messed up some of
the tech
and instead of doing what some of these
other projects have done when they have
to delay their launch because that's
actually pretty common
and say hey okay sorry we're gonna have
to delay
you know we'll give you 24 hours notice
before this thing drops it sort of kept
everybody on edge they didn't give us a
sense of like when the new eta was
so people were getting really mad
they're like this is disrespectful to
the community you're making us sit here
and
wait and waste our day um instead of
handling it the way you're supposed to
so
the cons seem to be they don't yet seem
to be really good at navigating like
the whole nft crypto community the pros
are that i think it's innovative and
super cool
and for that reason i'm gonna put some
heath towards it um but everyone should
check it out stoner cats stoner cats tv
see what you think we're investing
if we lose our shirt and this is like i
can't
i'm not investing enough to lose our
shirt don't invest so much that you're
going to lose
i can't tell if we're just bitter that
we missed on the gift goat
and like stoner cat is our like
consolation prize or
i'm kind of betting on the show being
good because that i think will bring
that yes throughout our community but
the fact that these celebs have not
tweeted about it makes me worry that
it's not very good
i don't think that's it i think they
just don't want to have to educate they
don't want to start answering questions
about like how do i get access to this
show
i mean look clearly spending eight
hundred dollars for 45 minutes of
content is an absurd value proposition
that's like
of course well you get other episodes
right or is it one you one token per
se no no each episode is like five or
six minutes
the episodes are really short they have
a total of 45 minutes of content for
this first drop
but then the idea is that they're going
to expand it to more content and as a
token holder
you have like say in what gets developed
and you get you know other perks
so there's a chance carly's making me
lose money again
again zach we don't have to rehash this
i did not make you lose money the first
time around
stoner cats it's stonercats.com you can
just i don't think is that what it is
yeah oh yeah oh yeah it's in ashley
kutcher's uh
instagram profile too um yeah yeah
ashton and melisa
um and by the way mila is sort of pro
the
billionaire space race and watching an
interview with her about stoner cats
she was like i think people are
misunderstanding the value of
this whole space race thing and she's
like i get the criticism but i think
it's people don't really understand
she talked about space race and stoner
cats she beat us the punch here i
thought this is the only podcast
ashton was an investor in virgin
galactic and mila told him he couldn't
go to space she was like absolutely not
you're not going to space i'm going to
space
carl i'm doing it yeah no i would not be
comfortable with that i would take the
total mila
approach and was like absolutely not
back this is what's going to happen
stoner cats
going to the moon and it's going to pay
for my virgin galactic
quarterback going to the moon space
tourist ride
and i'm going to be waiting there's a
pun stoner cats is going to go to the
moon
to fund your trip to the moon
i thought you were going like the cow
jumped over the moon type poem thing
uh we are now burning
the end of this podcast carl stoner cats
and billionaire space race an episode
for what do we call this for the record
books
um great to have you thank you for
keeping me great
i'm a co-host now great to have you zach
it's great to have you
i'm glad to be in your present we're out
have a good week everybody see you next
thursday everyone
you